[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARETH CHICK: Thank you.
Cultures of fear.
We're not in a culture
of fear in this--
an incredible organization.
Are we?
Let me tell you a little story,
which might at first seem
irrelevant to Google.
In 2010, the aircraft that was
taking the Polish president
from Warsaw to Minsk--
I don't know quite why he
was wanting to do that trip--
it crashed, killing 96 people
including the Polish president.
And the air accident
investigation report
blamed the pilots for trying to
land a plane in extraordinarily
bad weather conditions,
dangerously bad weather
conditions.
But they also placed blame
upon the Air Chief Marshal,
and they placed blame
upon the president.
Because the voice
recorder clearly
records one of the pilots at
a moment of decision saying,
he'll get mad.
If we don't land this
plane, he'll get mad.
And the report found that
the presence of the Air Chief
Marshal on the cockpit
at the moment when they
had to decide whether to land
the plane or abort because
of bad weather placed
psychological pressure
on trained professionals to go
against everything they knew.
What were they so afraid of?
He'll get mad.
The president at the
back of the plane
might even have been blissfully
unaware that this conversation
was taking place.
And yet his name
was taken in vain.
What were they so afraid of?
Now, you might say,
well, you know,
that's a weird example
to talk about here.
We are in the corporate world.
You know, that
wouldn't play out here.
Even if I was slightly
concerned about what
my boss might say if I did
or didn't do something,
nobody's going to die.
I'm not going to kill 96 people
if I make a wrong decision.
Well, maybe we'll come
back to that in a moment.
In 40 years in the
corporate world,
I came to realize that the
corporate world has the three
conditions for abuse
to be systemic.
And it's interesting, isn't
it, that abuse is a very, very
topical dynamic at the moment.
And quite rightly so.
Those three conditions
are we give power
to people over other people.
We certainly do that
in the corporate world.
And I don't really mind
how benign your manager is
or how loving or caring
they are, particularly
as we come up to par for
evaluation, what they think
and the power that they have
over us is definitely a factor.
The second condition is fear.
Corporations are
organized in hierarchies,
and there are a number of levels
even in this wonderful company.
And it was the hierarchy and
the fear of the hierarchy that
actually crashed the plane.
The hierarchy was sat
at the back oblivious,
and yet his name
was taken in vain.
And how guilty are we
sometimes of thinking,
well, I would do that, because
it seems like the right thing
to do.
But I'm not sure how that would
play out with Mountain View
or whoever it is that
we have this sort
of disembodied fear of.
And the third
condition is secrecy--
things that are behaviors
that are not witnessed.
Now in this organization,
again, lots of stuff
is done out in the open.
But even if it's
out in the open,
even if some of those
aberrant behaviors, who's
going to call them out?
When was the last time
you were in a meeting
where it was really
clear that there were
some inappropriate
behaviors in the room,
and not one person put their
hand up and said, please don't
talk to me like that?
Hmmm, I wonder why we allow
these things to happen.
Chris mentioned
that in the book,
I talk about two
characters in particular.
One of those I
call a corporapath.
This is a person with
power over other people.
They're not psychopaths.
They're not even sociopaths.
See them at home with their
families, and they're loving,
and they have empathy, and
they're beautiful human beings.
Put them under
pressure at work--
maybe for some very
stretching objectives,
or maybe even some
unreasonable expectations--
and suddenly the
empathy leaves the room.
And they start treating
people like, well, certainly,
not like people.
And that's OK, because those
behaviors are normalized.
And we go along with it, because
we're in the corporate world.
That's how people behave.
That'd be odd.
I wouldn't behave
like that at home,
but that seems to be the way
that things work around here.
And if you're going
to have corporapaths,
you also need the followers.
And that will be the rest of us.
And we become corporate
hostages, trapped
by all the positives, trapped
by the benefits, the equity,
even the fear of having
a limited amount of time
on the CV.
If some of you have been
here for-- if you have tenure
of a number of years--
you may have gone
through a process where
you got to a stage
and thought, actually,
it would be really
good for me to--
I really could do
something else.
Oh, hang on a second.
What's it going to look like
if I go to another employer,
and they say, oh only
two years at Google?
What was your problem?
Because it clearly
couldn't be the company.
And the more we
become the hostage
because we have to have a denial
about what is happening to us,
we come to love our abuser in
the corporate form of Stockholm
syndrome where we come to
say that we love our work.
And we do until the moment
when things catch up
with us a little bit.
I've coached more than
200 senior executives,
and I can't tell you
the number of times
I've had a senior
executive unload
for about 20 minutes on the
stress, and the pressure,
and the anxiety, and then
tell me, I love my job.
And I'm always thinking, OK.
And then I think, no, I
absolutely understand.
You have to tell yourself that.
Because when you're in
it, you have to be in it.
And when you know something
isn't quite right,
you can't know it.
It's called denial-- one of the
most powerful forces in nature.
I have been a corporapath,
particularly in my early days.
I was extremely arrogant.
And I had, you know, these sort
of the high read on insights,
and the ENTJ, and hard driving--
all those qualities
that we still
seem to prize the most
in corporations, drive--
that means aggression.
We don't call it aggression--
pace-- well, impatience
is another word for that.
Intellect, intellectual rigor.
We haven't got just
to know our numbers.
We've got to deeply,
deeply know our numbers.
And so we enter the madness
that is the corporate world.
But we collude with each other,
and we normalize all behaviors
and, you know, there's lots of
perks, and there's the food,
and there's the autonomy,
and there's the training.
Lovely.
But what I realized
was that actually there
is a unique anxiety disorder.
And we are all suffering
a mild or maybe
a slightly advanced form of this
anxiety disorder, me included.
You would have thought I
would've worked it out by now.
And I call it CTSD, Corporate
Traumatic Stress Disorder.
So you will know PTSD,
Post-traumatic Stress Disorder,
arrived on scene probably
about 20 years ago.
We know far more now
about what happens
to the human brain
and the human body
when we go through a trauma.
But of course, in
PTSD, it is linked
with a single violent
event, either a warfare
or a violent event
in the street.
Now, we know there's no
violence going on in this room.
There's no violence
going on in this office.
But the corporate
world has a low level
of persistent,
consistent anxiety--
small trauma almost every
minute of every day.
What time in the morning do
you check your first emails?
If it's 6:00 or
6:30 in the morning,
you can be checking your
emails, and you will already
be starting to run an unnatural
level of two stress chemicals,
adrenaline and cortisol.
Put a human being
under pressure,
and we perceive a threat.
And instantly, we get a
big spike in a chemical
called adrenaline,
which is designed
to pump the blood around our
body in a very different way.
Unfortunately, it
takes that blood away
from the thinking
part of my brain--
the part that is calm
and rational and the part
of my brain that can attach
me to my moral center
and regulate my emotions.
And, under pressure,
that part of my brain
shuts off, because if
I'm in survival mode,
I don't need that part
of my brain to survive.
I need my animal
instincts to survive.
Some of the blood goes
to my arms and my legs,
because I might need to
run away and have a fight--
and cortisol, a stress hormone.
Now, adrenaline will clear
the system fairly quickly.
Cortisol stays in the system
for quite a long time.
And cortisol is that
wonderful chemical--
not available online.
If you're in the street,
and you get a near miss--
taxi driver or
something-- and it's
that moment where you get
that frisson of stress.
And cortisol gives us
an intensity of focus.
It actually slows down time.
Which is why, when
you're under pressure,
and you ask one of your guys
one of those beautiful questions
that stops them in
their tracks and makes
them think for three seconds.
If you've got cortisol
banging around your system,
three seconds will
feel like a lifetime.
And it is highly likely that
you will be the very next person
to speak.
Answer your own question.
It's always much quicker.
And since we rarely ask
a question to which we
don't know the answer,
because actually
we're not really curious.
We like to manipulate people.
And we'll come onto
that maybe in a moment.
And when that part of
the brain shuts down--
so 100,000 years ago,
adrenaline, cortisol, survival.
Brilliant.
Needed them.
You know, spear,
mammoth, whatever
it was that was coming at me.
And maybe 100,000 years
ago, couple of times
a day, I might
have a five minute
spike in those chemicals.
I wonder what we, in
the corporate world,
I wonder what our levels
are like that we are not
biologically designed.
So we are rewiring
without even knowing it.
And actually what we're
doing is we are inflaming
our brain with the-- because
the stress, those chemicals,
they are quite toxic.
But it's very interesting
thing about brain,
the brain doesn't feel pain.
So our brains can get inflamed,
and we have absolutely no idea.
If any of you in this
room have suffered
what you might have
described as a burn out
or getting close to--
and I think there are many,
many moments when we get pretty
close to an edge-- and you know,
we might have a glass of wine,
or we might have a--
and if we've been married,
or we have a same life
partner that we've had
for a number of years,
they've got used to the
fact that we're all sick,
you know, the first
three days or holiday,
or we actually just sleep.
What are we doing to our bodies?
We don't even think about
it, because it's normal.
It's what everybody does
in the corporate world,
and we get incredibly well-paid.
And we can't leave.
Well, maybe, you know when
my stock options are a bit,
you know, maybe.
So, a few years
ago, a very wise guy
introduced us to the concept
of emotional intelligence.
Brilliant.
And Daniel Goleman.
And he said, it's really simple.
There is IQ, and
that's fantastic.
But we've overdone that a bit.
What we need is really EQ.
An emotional intelligence
is that very, very human--
like a higher level--
very human ability to have a
real sense of self-awareness.
Since I am aware
of how I am feeling
and how I'm likely to react, I
have a chance to self regulate.
So even if I'm in a
bit of fight or flight
and what I really want to do
is scream at you or smack you,
I know my emotional
intelligence can [EXHALING],,
and I can actually
regulate my responses.
But here's the thing.
When there is no blood
in my neocortex--
the largest part of our brain--
when there's no blood there,
emotional intelligence
doesn't do me any
good whatsoever,
because emotional intelligence
is only available to me
when I'm calm,
when I can actually
engage that rational part of my
brain, when I can attach myself
to my moral center, when I can
understand the emotions that
are happening to me.
If I'm in fight or
flight, then it's
just fear, terror,
petrification.
So we need a different
type of intelligence
to navigate this mad
world that we live in.
We need corporate
emotional intelligence.
And if you read
the book, there's
some stuff around what
the four pillars are.
I won't spoil that.
If I had an hour, I'd
bang on about those,
but I want to talk
about something else
before we finish.
Now, 2019, here we are.
We're in crisis.
In fact, there was a crisis
just about wherever we look--
crisis of politics.
I can't even bring
myself to talk about it.
In the UK, you have
your gilet jeune.
There's always
something going on.
And the world, you
know is migration.
The world is in crisis.
In fact, when you think
about what we now know,
we've known it for a long time.
And now we cannot
escape knowing it.
Climate change we are just
about at the point where we
could stop the worst excesses--
just about.
I don't see any
necessarily signs
that we as a human species
we're about to do that,
but now we know.
Amazing people
still some tonight.
We know we're
destroying the planet.
We know now that there is
a mass extinction going on.
Even just two or three weeks
ago, reports that around 60%
of insect species are
close to extinction.
The insects go, we go
very quickly afterwards.
The soil, we are
infecting the soil.
The oceans, we're in trouble.
And here we are in
our corporate world,
and we know these things,
but it feels too big.
What can I do?
I'm one person.
What can I do
about these things?
Well I'll draw you a parallel.
You see, I'm not
anti-corporation.
Corporation has provided
me with my livelihood,
and I'm very grateful.
I am a grateful
corporate citizen.
I'm not a socialist.
I have no desire to
overthrow capitalism.
But it is corporatism that
has created those things.
It is the separation of
ownership from responsibility
that has created the damage
we are doing to our planet.
And we are at a tipping point.
And we have to recognize
that our behaviors
as corporate citizens
have to change.
And even if we have things
like the Google Walk
Out for Real Change and then
maybe other ones to come--
even if we have those
things, fantastic movements--
are corporate leaders,
are business leaders,
and are political leaders
going to act in time?
Well, we can't wait.
Now, again, you say,
well, what can I do?
I'm one person.
Well I'm going to draw the
inextricable link for you
between how we behave with
each other in inhuman ways,
unnatural ways.
Here we are in our
corporate world.
And that for me is
the exact parallel
of what we are
doing to our planet.
And we are detached from that.
So, in your possession,
you may have
a t-shirt that was actually
made by a 9-year-old girl
in Bangladesh.
If you had to purchase it
from that 9-year-old girl,
you might have
changed your behavior.
But it's very easy and
we'll buy lots of them.
We all have a mobile phone.
Every single mobile phone
has got incredibly rare earth
precious metals.
Some 12-year-old boy,
with a gun to his back,
mined those metals in the
Democratic Republic of Congo.
We know this, but
we're still going
to go out and buy the
latest iPhone or the latest.
We're so divorced
from what's going on.
So here's what we need to do.
Because I'm not going to ask
you to go and change the world,
that would be fatuous.
I'm certainly not
going to do that.
I'm far too old and far too
lazy to even attempt that.
What I'm going to ask you
to do is to go and change
your piece of the world.
Because if we actually
started treating each other
like human beings again,
the world would change.
That is a complete act of faith,
that statement, on my part.
But I passionately
believe that to be true.
And it starts even
with some of the things
that Chris was talking
about, the way we actually
not just talk to each other,
the way we engage emotionally
with each other.
How many meetings do you go to?
How many theses do
you jump on one after
back to back, where actually
you are not emotionally engaged
with the person that
you are talking to?
You are in this
ludicrous transaction.
But you know the crazy
thing is that's my phone.
They obviously run
off pretty quick.
I know what they've done.
They thought, oh my god,
he's somewhere else.
This is going to cost
me a lot of money.
I'll put the phone
down immediately.
So that's what happened.
How we treat each other.
When you ask
somebody a question,
do you actually want
to know the answer,
or are you trying to tell
them what the right answer is?
Do you really want
to listen to them
or does that just take too
long, and if, you know,
they got to the point.
These are the small
areas that really
make a difference for us.
We are the first
generation that knows
we are destroying this planet.
We're the first generation
that knows that.
And we are the last generation
that can actually do anything
about it just about.
Now, we have, thankfully--
so my kids are in their 30s.
So we have Gen X,
Gen Y, millennials.
I think I'm Gen A. And
thankfully, they think and feel
differently to my generation.
Thank God that they do.
But millennials are not great
at governing themselves.
What they need is they
need some leadership.
They need some coaching.
And the wonderful thing about
coaching-- and of course,
I'm going to finish on a
passionate plea for you to be
better coaches--
the wonderful thing
about that is, even
in a moment where it's really
clear that the person that you
are engaging with has got
very high levels of adrenaline
and very high
levels of cortisol--
in which case, they are not
available to think rationally--
there's no point having
a fight with them.
There's no point dismissing
them or taking it back off them
and doing it yourself.
That's just going to
embed those behaviors.
But one carefully chosen
curious open question,
and they have to
engage and they have
to start putting some blood back
in this beautiful neocortex.
And the moment the blood
is back in the neocortex,
they become human again.
They are available
to engage with us
in a mission of curiosity.
When we're under pressure, our
default mode is impatience.
Our default mode is judgment,
because I mean fight or flight,
and you are the
cause of my threat.
That's not going
to get us anywhere.
Well, actually
where that gets us
is over oceans choked with
plastic and all the nonsense.
That's where that gets us.
When we start to engage
with each other, when
we turn our default mode from
impatience into curiosity,
the most attractive
of human qualities.
When we turn our default mode
of judgment into compassion,
then we will start changing
our part of the world.
You see, I don't want
you to go out and rebel
against your company and
go out on the streets
and say, you know, our leaders
have got to listen to us, and--
all right, you can.
There's always a
cool thing to do.
What I do want you to do is
I want you to go and change
your part of your world.
And I want you to have a
little bit more courage,
because you know, there are
things around you at the moment
that you are not doing that you
know that you probably should.
And for fear of a
consequence, a judgment,
we are so scared of what
people will think of us.
The threat to our
egos these days
feels way bigger than any
mortal or physical threat
that we may have
faced in the past.
And my brain cannot tell the
difference between a threat
to my physical being
and a threat to my ego.
It just knows its threat.
So go back and change
your part of the world.
I was really
fortunate 34 years ago
to learn a
transformational lesson,
because I was absolutely a
controller and a manipulator.
And I was really good at it.
And I probably could have
stayed and maybe for a few years
before I got found out.
And I learned the lesson
of changing my default mode
from impatience to curiosity.
And I practiced
having a default mode.
If somebody brought me a
piece of bad news or somebody
frustrated me
because I hadn't done
what they were supposed
to do or whatever it was,
I learned to smile.
I learned to see that there
was a beautiful flawed genius
of a human being who
was actually in pain.
And people, they won't tell
you the truth in that space.
I could get anybody to
say yes in that space.
It doesn't mean that
it's going to get done.
But just having a
moment of compassion
and being curious,
suddenly, in seconds,
we have that human
connection back.
Now we can do something
about changing
the way the world works.
So good.
I think it's time for some of
those fantastically beautifully
crafted open questions.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much
for this enlightening talk.
I think that many of the
things that you told us--
our kind, I mean we know that.
If we think about
it, we know that.
GARETH CHICK: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But at the same time,
there is a process or something
that happened into our
mind that say my mind--
just to make an example--
that prevents us from
staying in listening mode,
from staying curious
instead of being impatient.
So according to you,
what is a human being,
the element that
not does not allow
people that knows and want to
be open and in listening mode
to be there?
Is it fear?
GARETH CHICK: Yes.
You're right.
Good.
So the first thing
is to recognize it.
Hang on a second.
What is it that I
am feeling anxious?
What am I afraid
of at the moment?
Because in that moment, if you
ask yourself that question,
you will know exactly.
And then you have a choice.
Do I confront the fear,
or do I go with the fear?
The crazy thing about
the corporate world
is that there is so
much fear around,
and there doesn't need to be.
So I've coached so many execs
so, many leaders and managers,
who've said to me, well my boss
would never let me do that.
Or I've got a meeting
coming up with my boss,
and I think they're
going to say this.
On what evidence?
And they go and they
have a fantastic meeting
with their boss.
And I guess that
was a real surprise.
And it still doesn't
seem to stop them.
You know, when do
we actually get
to trust when our
boss says to us--
psychological safety-- please,
you know, take some risks.
Go can break a few
things you know.
And we think, yeah, ooohh, yeah,
but not sure they meant it.
That is exactly the
same as he'll get mad.
Exactly the same.
So notice what you're
fearful of and take courage.
And, if every single person
just went out this afternoon
and did one thing
that involved them
with a little bit
of courage, what's
the worst that can happen?
Somebody gets a bit
miffed with you.
Is that the worst
that can happen?
Nobody is going to die.
Your rating is not going
to suddenly plummet.
It feels like that sometimes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'll have to read
the book for the pillars,
but in short, what advise
would you give to a colleague
or family member that's stuck
in a situation where [INAUDIBLE]
path, and it's--
GARETH CHICK: Yeah?
SPEAKER 2: --rendering
their life quite miserable.
GARETH CHICK: Yes.
SPEAKER 2: From a management
to manager standpoint
or from an infusion
standpoint, what would you
recommend that they do?
GARETH CHICK: OK.
SPEAKER 2: --because
they can't quit the job.
So that's more of a
long term solution.
GARETH CHICK: That's right.
Well, so notice actually this
is, in a sense, almost exactly
the same advice that you
would give to somebody
who was in a domestic
violence situation, somebody
who is being held hostage--
extreme language I know--
but the advice is the same.
Because if you want to salvage
your health and your mental
well-being--
60% of people suffer some sort
of mental illness or episode
at work--
60%-- but here's the choice.
You either have to leave,
or you have to overthrow.
Whistleblowing is really rea--
I don't know that many
whistleblowers that are,
you know, glad they did it--
but it is an option.
Or you have to endure.
But if you're going
to endure, you
have to turn it into a positive.
So the way to turn
it into a positive
is, OK, I'm working
for a corporapath.
It's very unpleasant.
I'm not dying.
What am I learning here, and
for how long will I do this?
Because anybody can
put up with anything
for a short period of time.
OK.
I will do this for
another six months,
and then I will see where
I am and make a decision.
See, you have to
help that person,
because leaving
probably, you know--
I mean at some point,
health has to come before.
If it's a partner,
then one of the things
is they don't want
to let you down.
If they were on their own,
they'd probably leave.
But they don't want to let down.
How many of you feel
obligated to carry
on earning what you are earning
maybe if your partner is either
at home and not
earning or has a--
yeah-- oh, the stories,
the fear that we
have of going into the unknown.
Wow.
We have to make a
positive choice.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I wonder-- so the
most things that you described
are on an individual
level, and we all
know that the only thing we
can change is ourselves first.
But what could you do on
a more corporate level?
I mean, what could we do to
create organizations that
do not enforce those behaviors?
GARETH CHICK: So I really don't
want to be a harbinger of doom,
but so many things have been
tried over so many years.
And corporatism has the most
beautiful survival instinct.
So governments will change
legislation and say,
we'll regulate, and this
will bring the corporations
into line.
And then armies-- anybody in
here a lawyer or an accountant
or married to a
lawyer or accountant?
Ah, what the hell?
I'll take the risk.
The parasites who feed
off will just create,
because the
corporation will say,
well you know, if
we're regulated,
that will cost us $15
million, or if we're regulated
or we might be fined.
I mean, organizations
getting fined?
My word.
So it's worth paying
half a million euros
to get some legal and
accounting advice,
and we'll get around it.
Every single thing, every
single regulation, people
can get around.
Now, at some point, because
we're at a tipping point,
there may be a movement.
There may be a revolution
of some kind maybe,
but there's nothing that we as
individuals can do about that.
We can go on streets,
put on a yellow vest
or whatever the-- we
can do those things.
But we can change our
piece of the world.
We can.
We can say, I'm not
going to do things
that I know that don't
feel right to me.
I'm not going to
do them anymore.
And the amazing thing
is that probably
will get positive
feedback when we
actually-- because our bosses
want us to be free of fear.
The crazy thing is--
I mean, I understand working
for an intimidating boss
when you anticipate an angry
reaction, that's a horrible,
and that is abusive.
But it's even more
intimidating to work for a boss
that you love and see a look of
disappointment in their eyes.
Oh my God, I can't have that.
I can't dis--- yeah.
And so we put a fear
around ourselves.
The only thing we can
do is ask ourselves,
what's one thing I could
do this afternoon that
would be more
integral, that would
be more attached to my moral,
that would be more courageous
of me?
Go do it.
And the world would do
what it's going to do.
Don't think we should sound
fatalistic and yet I have.
We have time for, oh, yes
just two or three more.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So can you tell
us more about the turning
point from a corporate path
to a compassionate person?
Is that someone else bringing
it to your attention?
GARETH CHICK: It was a
very interesting moment.
So I was 29, and I was a CFO
of a public company in the UK.
And I'd been a CFO for
public since I was 25--
the youngest youngest ever.
I was the youngest ever this
and the youngest ever that.
And I was married.
I had two children.
I had a four bedroom house.
I mean, I was the
archetypal career driven--
I was a nightmare, really.
I was.
And my boss-- chief
exec at the time,
he was brilliant-- he
took me to one side
and gave me some
really tough feedback.
And he said, you're good,
but you are about to fail.
I'm going to send you
on a leadership course.
I cannot tell you how
cynical I was when I--
It is part of the reason I do
the trainings and these moves.
It's the part of the reason
I do the training now,
because I know what
it's like, and I
know how I was sitting in
training, thinking, come on,
yeah, I know all this, or
you don't know how busy I am.
I would do all of that.
He sent me on this course,
and I behaved very badly
on the first morning.
I was cynical, and I was surly,
and I was looking at my watch,
and yeah, yeah, and we didn't
have email in those days.
But I would have been
the one constantly
checking the phone, not
really engaged, and saying,
oh just, you know,
I'm really sorry,
but I've got to jump on
a call for half an hour.
I'll come back, and
then it's an hour.
I would that would
have been that person.
My instructor,
Walter Blackburn--
he's acknowledged in
the front of the book--
and he saw this, and
he took me to one side.
He metaphorically stuck
his hand under my chin
and put me up against the wall
and said, you need to grow up,
or you need to go.
But if you're going to stay
here, you need to get involved.
I don't think anybody really
spoken to me like that before.
He knew what he was doing.
He knew how to do that
with me in a way that
would win my respect.
That was a turning point,
because I threw myself in.
And the reason I had
this crazy, you know,
full time CEO whatever and
part-time leadership trainer is
partly why my first marriage
didn't last that long-- well,
and I was a bit of an asshole--
that is why then I asked to go
and learn how to train others
with that course.
I became evangelistic
about coaching.
It really taught me some
emotional intelligence,
and it taught me how to coach.
It taught me that beautiful
transformational moment
as a coach, when you
can have a person--
you can release all of that
potential, and ingenuity,
and humanity they
have, and they will
perform to an even higher
level, because that's
what they want to do.
Yeah.
It was transformational.
AUDIENCE: You talk
about people with drive.
And you said, it's aggression.
GARETH CHICK: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sound like
kind of picturing them
in a negative way.
If we were--
GARETH CHICK: I was.
AUDIENCE: --all more
human as you suggest,
do you think the corporations
would be more efficient or less
efficient?
GARETH CHICK: Absolutely
more efficient.
I've had some
interesting conversations
with some senior Google leaders
about psychological safety,
for example.
And every one of them says our
psychological safety really,
really important.
And when I asked
them to describe
what behaviors they
exhibit to actively create
psychological
safety, they struggle
to tell me those things.
They make it sound really
great, but it goes on
for about five minutes.
And I have really no
idea what they've said,
because they haven't really
answered the question.
And then I say how
do you measure it?
And they say, well, we have
this Google guy stand, you know,
whatever.
OK.
Which questions actually show me
that you have a psychologically
safe workforce?
Ah, Well.
So the reality is that
when we're on-- listen.
You've got some fabulous
leaders, fabulous leaders,
some of the best in the world.
But they are also human, and
therefore, under pressure, they
can flirt with some of those
corporapathic behaviors.
And here's the issue.
Under pressure, some
of those leaders
are found out occasionally,
because here's
what I think internally.
It's coming up to the end
of Q1, we're short of quota.
If I make people feel too safe,
then they'll go a bit soft.
They will breathe
a sigh of relief.
They will realize that
they're quite tired,
and that's my quota gone.
So actually I can't have
people feeling too safe.
I don't want you
to feel threatened.
I don't want them
to feel fearful.
Well, you can't have one or the
other, because you hold power.
If I hold power, I don't need to
do anything to intimidate you,
because I have power.
I have to massively
over index on that.
So there are countless
examples I could give you
of where true psychological
safety delivers
phenomenal results, because
people, when they feel safe,
they get incredibly creative.
You don't hire dullards.
You hire brilliantly
well-qualified people.
All they want to do
is do fabulous work.
That's all they want to do.
Leave them to
their own devices--
bit of governance,
bit of coaching--
just wear them what we have
to do for the millennials--
and they will fly.
We haven't begun to
see what people can do.
Now, it's crazy thing to say--
and this organization that's
only 20 years old, there's
now 100,000 of you,
and you make $5 billion
every 10 minute.
I understand that.
But actually how long
will that continue?
You've got competitors
taking share of you
right, left, and center.
I wonder.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you Chris.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.